welcome to the michaela peterson podcast
in this episode i spoke with hamilton
morris
this is his second appearance on my
podcast but first appearance with
video hamilton morris knows more about
drugs than anyone i know
he's also a very interesting person
reminds me of someone from a sherlock
holmes novel
he's an american journalist chemist and
scientific researcher
the creator and director of the
television series hamilton's
pharmacopoeia
which just finished its third season
i used him to ask about my experience
with mdma and s house rise
bad idea folks this was as a much
younger adult
by the way we also covered xenon gas
eboga ceremonies pharmaceutical safety
those are also drugs guys and more
this episode is brought to you by raw
optics
you know those glasses i wear in my
podcast profile
they're from raw optics blue light
blocking glasses
not only do they look cool in my humble
opinion
but they can help prevent eye strain
headaches migraines daytime sleepiness
nighttime wiredness and more they block
blue light that basically tells your
brain it's supposed to be the morning
given the fact that everyone's glued to
their screens these days
these bad boys are pretty important they
have daylight
and nighttime glasses the daylight ones
have glasses that block less blue light
so you end up looking like a nerd no i'm
just kidding these are great
so you end up not falling asleep during
the day i found the red ones useful
for helping me get tired at night
particularly if i'm looking at screens
before bed
which unfortunately i do go to
rawoptics.com
map that's r a like the sun god
rawoptics.com map it's linked below
or use code map at checkout for 10 off
ideally guys use the link if you want
these
fancy glasses which i honestly love
the code is map because my middle name
is alexis
and these guys didn't want to use mp so
that's
raoptics.com map this episode is also
brought to you by trulocal
if you want to feel really good don't do
drugs kids eat meat
true local is my go-to meatbox company
and now delivers to a ton of places in
the states too they're expanding
they're taking over i haven't had
delivered meat that's better
i can seriously say that i'd recommend
their grain-fed beef
it's what i like i like it better wild
salmon and their lamb
is to die for they also have other cuts
i've heard are tasty they have liver
pork chicken sausages etc
tru local.ca code mp for free steaks
i seriously recommend these guys for
meat i know they're doing some veggies
too but i haven't tried those
myself truly codemp
enjoy this episode please subscribe if
you do episodes every sunday and
wednesday have a wonderful week
[Music]
hamilton morris welcome back to the
podcast
thanks for having me it's nice to see
you again and this time we have video
so that's good yeah have you been
i've been okay i'm still kind of
recovering from
i'm a hell of a lot better than i was
when we did the first podcast
like i don't know if that was i don't
know when that was
april or something or may or march
but um better than then for sure
how are you doing i'm doing all right
yeah that was a
crazy time it still is a crazy time of
course but that was really the uh
the height of it yeah i
was yeah it was
so you've just finished releasing the
third season
of hamilton's pharmacopoeia that's right
yeah
the finale aired this week and
it is i hope going to be available to
people to actually watch at some point
in the future because
the major question that i get from
people is just how to watch it
um and you know most
people most millennials at least i don't
even think have tvs anymore
and if you're not in the united states
it can be hard to get it on amazon
or itunes so i'm hoping that it'll be on
hulu soon i have no idea when
but it's it's out there people are
pirating it it's getting circulated so
that's
something he's not suggesting pirated
it's out there to be pirated um and it's
available right now on amazon in the
states yeah that's the easiest way to
watch it is just to
buy it for i think the whole season's 15
on amazon i don't make any money from it
i'm just saying that's the easiest
way and the ones that are ripped how can
you not make any money from it that
seems like a bad deal
how did that happen yeah i think it's a
pretty standard deal i don't
actually it's so hard to know because i
you know i'm not i never
studied uh journalism or or
television broadcasting or anything like
that and i don't know all that many
other people that
make tv shows so i don't know what
standard or what
is typical but yeah i certainly have
never
made any money from people watching it
you know
and i don't know if people typically do
i kind of imagine they don't
i feel like they probably get bought out
right you probably sell it to netflix
and then you get a lump sum and then
it doesn't really matter how it performs
you just get that amount of money
i think that's how it works i don't know
how amazon works
right and netflix doesn't even tell
people how well their things do
typically i mean it's kind of a black
box okay so what was
um what was xenon gas like
xenon gas was um
well one theme of the season was
the synthetic natural dichotomy but also
the way our impression of a substance
alters the experience the way
the sort of cultural historical matrix
that a substance exists within
uh impacts the the actual
drug effect because sometimes we tend to
reduce these things to pure pharmacology
and not think about well what does it
mean if something is perceived as
natural what does it mean if something
is perceived as synthetic what does it
mean if something is perceived as
ancient
and i think xenon at least for me
is this very powerful
instance of that it's this substance
that is an element you know on the
periodic table of elements you have
the rightmost column which are called
the noble gases and at the top you have
helium then you have neon
argon krypton xenon
and radon below that and uh
and these are substances that are
considered completely unreactive and
that
in and of itself is a bit confusing to
people because they'll say
okay if this is a chemical that is
completely
unreactive then how on earth is it
inducing a physiological
effect in my body which i think is a
kind of a valid
question um and so i think there's a lot
to learn
from it and a lot of interesting aspects
i mean the answer to the question is
that
not most pharmacological interactions
aren't the result of like a covalent
bond forming between the drug and the
receptor or something like that it's
these uh non-covalent forces where
a drug can just by virtue of its shape
and charge uh interact with the specific
site on a receptor and that's what xenon
is doing at the
glycine site of the nmda receptor but um
but you know so what does it feel like
it's it's like
it's inextricably linked to its
preciousness
to its rarity to the
difficulty of actually extracting it
from the air that we breathe
so um you know i think with like alcohol
for example there's often these very
complicated narratives that are
constructed in order to sell a specific
alcohol like
this was aged in a oak barrel in
france for 50 years and then when you
drink it you think oh wow
to think this was in a an oak barrel for
longer than i've been alive how cool
that's nice
like that's something um and
and with xenon yeah there's
a little bit of that same feeling of of
like
i don't know just like wow this was just
part of the air
that people have been breathing since
the beginning of
time on earth and uh and someone
compressed all that air to a liquid and
distilled off
all the different gases and then we're
left with this fraction of xenon that's
like point zero zero
zero zero zero five percent of the
atmosphere it's kind of amazing and that
it was synthesized in the star
which everything is but like but just to
i don't know it's all this thing i i
think all that comes into the experience
in a way that um with nitrous oxide it's
like
okay someone like decomposed um
you know like ammonium nitrate or
whatever the industrial process
is i guess in the video i make it also
with uh
hydroxylamine hydrochloride and sodium
nitrite
um but yeah so
so is it fun is it fun yeah it's fun i
guess that's a shorter answer yeah it's
really fun
and it's very euphoric and um
and and
i i think that it is
based on what is known about it it's
very safe as well
um there's a pharmaceutical company
that's actually developing a xenon
inhaler
for ptsd uh right now i got to play
around
in the states in the states yeah they
actually sent me the prototype of the
inhaler which never made it into the
episode
i mean how do you get these things just
like hamilton this isn't available
to anybody but you can have one of these
it didn't it was
it was just a prototype to like for me
to
hold in my hand and look at um it's
really cool
it's i mean it's the first time
i've ever seen a psychoactive drug
inhaler
of any kind that was used
pharmaceutically um
so you know i think that's really cool
that they're they're doing that
i think that in general there's a trend
toward fast acting
treatments which is something that uh
non-medical recreational drug users have
recognized from the very beginning you
know if there's one
characteristic that you know so-called
recreational
drugs or non-medical drugs have is that
they're typically fast
acting you know you don't hear people
saying like oh yeah
i've got like an untreated anxiety
disorder but like
i find this uh if i take like a micro
dose of some herb for three months like
it starts to help me out a little bit
like people want results and uh and so
i i could imagine someone who's in the
midst of a
panic attack or having some kind of
anxiety
inhaling a breath of xenon gas and
feeling
at peace it's very very relaxing
um and and ultimately it's very similar
to nitrous oxide it's stronger by weight
um but but it's it's
cooler although nitrous oxide is also
very cool
and and really the coolness of a drug
should not be uh
like the deciding factor and it's it's
pharmacological medical utility but
it is a factor it's a factor for me um
so yeah it's and and then of course
um you know when i you've seen the
episode i
assume yeah yeah so uh yeah
you know i i feel a little bit bad
about because when i make these things
like i i'm not one of these
i don't even really consider myself a
journalist to begin with very much but
uh i'm certainly not one of these
journalists it's like trying to make
people look bad or trying to catch them
catch them doing something naughty you
know that's just not
my interest in this i would prefer if at
all possible to make people
look good and to you know use uh use the
platform to try to
show people who are misunderstood by
society show the value of their beliefs
or challenge the beliefs that the viewer
might have in some way
and with the xenon clinic it was a bit
tricky
because i was finding myself in um
in the midst of something that was like
starting to feel like an expose that i
never intended to create
that was not i wasn't going there to
show you know these xenon clinics in the
czech republic they are very
unscrupulous in their practices and
someone has got to make sure that xenon
is regulated in the future that was
not at all what i was trying to do and
and i also never want to
report in such a way that it will
result in any kind of like new
prohibitions i'm very aware of the way
journalists have historically
contributed to the war on drugs via
scare stories
so um so i'm also hyper aware of that
and um and really more than anything
what i wanted to communicate
by showing that was just the potential
not to say that this is something that
will absolutely happen but
i believe um i believe that
that man who died is not the first
xenon clinic operator to have died in
the czech republic i think that there
was another one before him although i
need to
i need to corroborate that but that
is what i believe i was told early on in
discussions
and then um
yeah i think that the people that have
unlimited access to this hyper-euphoric
gas
that is arguably the perfect drug right
with the exception of its cost based on
what is currently known about it
it is you know non-toxic it's not
biotransformed in any way you inhale it
you exhale it
nothing happens to the xenon it's it's
essentially unreactive under
physiological conditions
and then and then you have this euphoric
state with no hangover
arguably it's even good for you right i
mean that's why it's used as a
performance-enhancing drug
so i could see how if you have a
gigantic tank
of this um how it could get
very easy to use it excessively
and to get into trouble with it yeah so
this might be an
uneducated question well it definitely
is but
if you're inhaling a gas and it's not
reacting with you exactly does that mean
it's just
because okay okay i'll back up a little
bit when we went to
russia and to serbia to get my dad like
neurological
help and we went to some of the really
high-end clinics they all had xenon gas
and it was something they'd been using
for decades no way um
oh yeah oh yeah it was for it was for
um brain injuries or strokes
like they've been using it in russia and
serbia and they had been it was
the norm um that's something although
expensive
did your father use xenon he tried it
yeah
oh wow he he liked it
but it wasn't it didn't seem to be you
know it wasn't magical or something like
it
he it seemed to like make him relax a
little bit and they said that there were
potential
anti-anxiety benefits and it was
potentially good for brain health
but it wasn't it wasn't transformative
but i was wondering how it worked
because
you know it's not supposed to really
change when you inhale it so is it just
cutting off oxygen what does it do
no when it gets in right that's a good
question
yeah they they know within they have a
hypothesis that seems valid for how it
works which is
um you know there historically there
have been a lot of
different hypothetical mechanisms for
how anesthetics work
and the kind of the oldest one that's
semi-evidence-based is called the meyer
overton hypothesis have you heard about
this
it's it's like uh they these two
pharmacologists found that there was a
really strong correlation
between how fat soluble an anesthetic is
and how potent it is and so they were
able to
show that as these anesthetics become
increasingly soluble in fat
they become increasingly potent and they
hypothesized the
reason for this was that they were
causing some kind of sort of
non-specific
phospholipid membrane disruption and
that was the mechanism
but then the main challenge to that
hypothesis
was that you know some molecules are
handed
like our hands they they're like mirror
images of each other that are
non-superimposable
and uh and they found that some of these
handed or chiral molecules um
had different interactions with the
receptor depending on which hand which
would indicate that it is
but even though these compounds had the
exact same fat solubility they had
different potency so then that was the
first kind of [ __ ] in the armor
of this hypothesis and um
and then later they started to recognize
that
the action of anesthetics was a drug
like action
where they're acting on a specific
receptor they have a specific
pharmacology
and so then the question became okay
well which receptor is it that they're
acting at
and the idea behind xenon is that it is
acting at
a subtype of glutamate receptor called
the nmda receptor yeah
okay yeah and that uh and that
you know in order for this central
channel in
the nmda receptor to open and allow
positively charged ions into the neuron
um these two agonists have to bind to
the receptor site
one is glycine the other is glutamate
and so
when okay hypothetically when xenon
binds
at the glycine site it prevents glycine
binding therefore it it interferes with
this
necessary process to open the channel so
you're preventing
the introduction of positive ions into
the neuron which then
in turn uh prevents firing action
potentials that sort of thing so
um that's the hypothetical mechanism
of xenon at the nmda receptor
but um it is not oxygen
deprivation and and the i uploaded a
video to youtube of myself
inhaling xenon and uh and of course all
these people were writing that like
this idiot has no idea what he just did
that's brain damage
he thinks he's high that's just his
brain being damaged by oxygen
deprivation
okay well um no because
first of all i it would have been no
longer than holding my breath
for you know whatever a minute and no
one is saying that that
causes brain damage um but
more importantly there is a specific
pharmacological action and if you were
to inhale xenon or rather a helium or
one of the
other noble gases that does not have
this action at the nmda receptor
you will not have an anesthetic effect
you will
remain and people do it all the time you
know from inhaling
helium balloons if it caused a powerful
anesthetic effect we would have
recognized that a long time ago okay
okay that that explains some things i've
been trying to figure out
what it worked on so nmda receptors that
makes sense that also explains why it
can be
relaxing to use so that makes sense my
question was coming from
like i said an uneducated place based on
my experience in grade six when i
inhaled a helium balloon and then
without
inhaling any ox i just breathed out and
then i inhaled another helium balloon
and i almost fell over because i wasn't
i don't know what i was inhaling but it
was enough balloons that i was like
oh i'm pretty pretty lightheaded and
clunk
that's where it's coming from my grade
six question about whether or not it's
like helium
repeated helium balloons and of course
it could cause
oxygen deprivation it could that that is
a you know if you were to only inhale
xenon it won't oxygenate your cells and
you will
at some point uh start to suffer the
effects of
hypoxia so that's you know that is but
they use oxygen with
the encode yeah
good good to know i'm glad i figured
that out yes
mostly i just wanted to tell my helium
balloon story it shocked me in grade six
i was like
oh this was fun but i almost passed out
uh okay okay next question considering
you're my like
kind of pharmaceutical guy this is a
personal story too
um i used to so i took ssris for like 11
or 12 years
and uh i tried
mdma while i was on ssris and this was
because
i'd been taking them since i was 12 so
they were they were kind of just part of
me
and i didn't really think of myself as
being on drugs
right which i know now is is wrong even
if it's something like an ssri it's
still a drug
so i tried mdma and i tried it a couple
of times and it never
did anything so my pupils wouldn't even
dilate
yeah so i'd be with friends and i'd end
up i was young and i was stupid and i'd
end up taking enough and i was like it's
not working it's not working you know
more and more
and my friends would be high
very high and i'd be like my pupils
aren't even dilating why doesn't it work
on me
and i took a a neuro psych
some sort of psych course in university
and i asked the professor
the professor professor was just like
whoa i don't even know where to go with
that
but do you have any idea why a serotonin
reuptake inhibitor would stop
mdma from working yeah i can i can
give you like a a potential explanation
although i think that
this explanation is not perfect so
uh the basic the basic pharmacology of
mdma
is you have this protein called the
serotonin transporter
that is responsible for shuttling
serotonin out of the presynaptic neuron
into the synaptic cleft where it then
activates the postsynaptic neuron
and uh and when you have a
uh a serotonin reuptake inhibitor like
prozac um it is going to
block the serotonin transporter so that
serotonin remains in the synaptic cleft
and it's not
shuttled back into the presynaptic
neuron so
that's like that's the idea but then uh
mdma
is also acting via the serotonin
transporter
to release serotonin into the synaptic
class so they're both
both ssris and mdma are both acting on
the serotonin transporter
and they're both uh increasing the
concentration of serotonin
in the synaptic cleft but the uh
pharmacologies of the two
have a potentially opposing effect where
one requires uh
blockade of that transport protein or
somehow reducing the functionality of
that transport protein
and the other requires a sort of
reversal of
the transport so that it's exiting the
presynaptic
neuron and entering the synaptic cleft
so
you have like one one is like uh is like
blocking the door
and the other is changing the
directionality of the flow
so i think hypothetically what's
happening is that
you have the uh the blockade of
the transporter is preventing
release of serotonin from the neuron um
and and for that reason there have
actually been quite a lot of studies
done that show that
ssris attenuate the neurotoxicity or the
potential neurotoxicity of mdma
and the the hypothetical reason is that
it's blocking the
mechanism of mdma um so
that's that's the expert but here's why
i say that this explanation is not
entirely satisfactory
is with other drugs that have that type
of pharmacology specifically with
something like amphetamine so
amphetamine
um releases dopamine
similarly to the way mdma releases
serotonin which also releases dopamine
there's a lot of
pharmacological overlap between these
substances but with amphetamine
it's primarily dopamine that's being
released but if you combine
amphetamine with a dopamine reuptake
inhibitor like
methylphenidate um then you
don't experience this blockade of
effects right
instead there's an additive effect
between the two it's it's not like if
you took um
adderall and ritalin you would they
would cancel each other out they don't
there's an additive effect between the
two of them
and i can't explain why that is but it's
a
it's interesting i'm you know this is
interesting yeah
so and i'm sure there is a reason i'll
i'll figure it out one day but
um but yeah so that's that's the idea is
that
uh prozac is basically interfering with
the mechanism
of mdma and that's a pretty
common thing for people to experience to
either have to take enormous doses of
mdma
uh if they have taken ssris for a long
time and
uh there's even some suggestion that
probably at the extremes there could be
some danger in the interaction but it
doesn't seem
in most instances that that is the case
interesting well that certainly like it
was shocking to me because i didn't know
what i was doing and i was like
18 or 19. i was like how does this
i'm just immune it's got to be the
antidepressant but then why would that
work i thought
that's supposed to increase serotonin
and was like this would be an
interesting question for a professor and
he just looked at me like
in horror i mean it's a shame because
it's actually been studied
a lot you know it's been studied
extensively
because this was kind of one of the the
big mechanistic questions of mdma is
is and actually a lot of other potential
serotonergic neurotoxins is like
you want to see how you can block that
toxicity and in terms of the
published research um the use of an ssri
of some type
is probably the most effective way
to block that toxicity it's not
selective you're also blocking the
effect of the drug as well so it's not
uh yeah it's not like some kind of
miracle cure for
uh to prevent the toxicity of mdma
although there's been a sort of like
um harm reductionist move where some
people advocate for
the use of prozac in the wake of an mdma
experience to try to attenuate any
potential toxicity
that has not been uh carefully
investigated in humans as like to assess
the
validity of that as a neuroprotective
intervention but it seems like it's
well tolerated by most people
wow that's interesting okay i'm going to
add another factor into this story
so one of the one of these times that i
tried mdma and it didn't work
um it was probably
seven hours later and i went home and i
had a cough
so this wasn't on purpose but i had a
cough i took my antidepressant so it was
it was cyprelax and it was on i was on a
lot of it
i took my antidepressant and i had some
cough syrup with dextromethorphin in it
and i went to bed and it wasn't to get
some sort of high
it was to go to bed and i'd noticed as a
kid that whenever i'd take
cough syrup i'd get kind of stoned and i
had no idea so i'd been avoiding cough
syrup but i had this cough it was
keeping me awake so i took cough syrup
went to bed
an hour later i woke up with what i now
think is serotonin syndrome
i had a fever i threw up i started
hallucinating and was just like
whoa maybe that combination of mdma
earlier in the day and an antidepressant
and and cough syrup was a
like a really bad idea but the fact that
i hadn't even noticed any effect from
the mdma and then i'd had a tiny bit of
cough syrup and
got like i'm sure it was serotonin
syndrome because i'd had
somewhat similar reactions to cop syrup
before but um
do you have any knowledge about the
interaction between dextromethorpene
specifically
and ssris yes yeah that's a it's a
documented phenomenon that has been
described in i think the medical
literature and
anecdotally in the kind of forums for
some time it seems that there is a uh
a potentially toxic interaction between
mdma and dextromethorphan and that was
uh exacerbated by the fact that
at least in the past a number of like
ecstasy tablets also contained dxm as an
additive and i think that would cause
negative experiences for people but yeah
it's
it's it's probably operating on a couple
it would i'd have to know the exact
doses of everything to even
kind of assess exactly what happened but
at the very least yeah it seems like
it uh produces an unpleasant effect for
most people and i
there is a suggestion that it can cause
serotonin syndrome as well
okay interesting very interesting
um do you do breath work i think i read
something online about your experience
with breath work
uh i not regularly i i
for sports credit in high school took a
kundalini yoga class
and uh and i i have done
so i did kundalini yoga in high school
and
uh i went to a pretty alternative high
school
[Laughter]
and uh and then and then you know i've
done meditation and things like that on
and off and i've done like a holotropic
breath work class i mean it's clear that
you can achieve an altered state from
the sort of breath work i've experienced
it myself
um there's a lot of ways to achieve
interesting altered states without the
use of some
exogenous drug but
it's never been something that i've been
able to incorporate into my
daily practices beneficially maybe i'm
just too
especially now i'm so distracted all the
time it's like
i feel like this pandemic has just uh
like forced everyone to be in front of
their computers all day i don't know
like what you're situ in new york in the
winter time yeah
it's bad it's bad i'm on my it's
ridiculous
especially if you work from home then
and you're prone to overworking then you
never stop working
and so i get up in the morning and i'm i
used to be disciplined with like not
looking at my phone for a while
and meditating and doing exercise and
then i got
just stressed to death this year um
dealing with my dad and then this
pandemic and now i've just been like i'm
just working from like
nine in the morning to 10 30 at night
it's insane on my computer
yeah i'm going to look like mr burns
everyone we're going to come out of this
and we're going to all be mr burns
yeah it's not it's not uh oh
where are you are you in a warm place
you're in new york
yeah i'm in toronto so we've been on a
mandated like
everything is closed um it's only
essential businesses that are open we're
supposed to be staying inside
and it's been like two and a half months
um november 23rd i think so people are
going kind of crazy here
yeah yeah i mean i haven't oh man yeah
it's
it's wild so i'm just i probably should
start meditating because i am so
distracted like there's something about
not going outside
it being winter just being in my vaguely
prison cell like apartment um like
all day every day uh it's it's like
yeah it's not it's not helping my
ability to
to focus so i would i would like to
incorporate
something if it helped but you know i
try all these things and they all kind
of work like someone just sent me this
cool
um iphone app that like turns the
flashlight of your
iphone into a strobe light and then you
stare at the
stroboscopic flashlight and it induces
some kind of
you know it's it's cool it works it's
you know there is like a
i was getting sort of vaguely
interesting visual patterns and things
like that but then i i wonder like okay
that's cool
that works but how do i integrate that
into my life in such a way that it is
beneficial like i don't know
yeah it also like um
the amount of stress people are under
right now even just
even if you have it good even if you
have a job that you can do out of your
house
right good compared to other people even
just the fact that you're not seeing
people and going outside
it gets wearing like i'm going i'm going
nuts
inside um and i most people i know are
very
volatile so it's hard to be like you
know what and people manage it but it's
hard to you know i'm going to
incorporate exercise in i'm going to do
a little bit of meditation every day
which would ultimately make you feel
better but it's also difficult if you're
under enough stress
that staring at your computer screen is
more
gives you more of an instant
gratification yeah i mean running from
running is for me the thing that uh
achieves a lot of the things that i
think other people are able to achieve
via meditation and breath work i think
it forces me
into all of those things like when i run
i don't
listen to music i don't have any
electronics on me whatsoever
and it kind of forces me
to focus on my breathing forces me to
like empty my head for a little while if
i'm feeling angry i can immediately
uh like use that anger
to propel the exercise
beneficially and now it's like the
streets are covered in snow
there's nowhere to run everything is
slippery it's just uh
it's it's really and running is the is
kind of
the only thing like that that has ever
worked for me
so not being able to run as well is like
not uh not helping things out
yeah that's no fun yeah you could get
it depends what size your apartment is
but you could try and get a treadmill
that's just gonna take up your apartment
it would be like my entire apartment
would be
a treadmill and i'd have to like eat
sitting on a treadmill
but i could maybe it's worth it
i got this machine and it's like a
rowing machine kind of and a squat
i can't run because i have my ankle
replaced and i really can't run on that
ankle it's it's pretty good for a fake
ankle but it's not good enough to run
on and so i got this machine where it's
kind of like a squat
and a row machine so it's definitely for
like
old women but um you kind of bounce up
and down on it
and you use the handlebars um
and it's small and it works really well
i'll send you a link after okay
and it's kind of funny to do if you're
if you haven't been entertained in a
very long time so you
you laugh easily because everything's
depressing
it might entertain you uh
okay let's switch um i i was
youtubing you a little bit earlier and i
saw the
and i think we covered this last time
but i want to do it again anyway um
the iboga ceremonies
where so i want you to get into that a
little bit where people are
buried yeah to experience this boga
ceremony can you get into that a bit
yeah yeah i think um i'd read about it
in some of the older
anthropology literature from the 60s and
i'd kind of
wondered there's always a question when
you read any
anthropology work or see a documentary
or whatever any documentation of a
practice you wonder
was that just of that time was it just
of that group
is that does everyone do that do they
still do it today
and so i didn't know whether that would
still be practiced and i was
there's something so visually and
symbolically beautiful and interesting
about being buried alive for therapeutic
purposes
like i really like that idea um and i
think that there's something
something about these sorts of um
very intense symbolic rituals
that is totally missing from the way we
practice
medicine like you know what does it do
to a person
to be symbolically buried alive and to
spend the night in a grave
staring at the stars what does that do
to a person psychologically um
that's not the kind of thing that the
fda is going to approve
in a clinical trial like being buried
alive is a therapeutic
intervention but um and it sounds
and it sounds ridiculous this will make
you feel better right it sounds
ridiculous like to even
to even suggest being buried alive as a
therapeutic intervention to anyone
involved in
in any kind of like mental health care
they would almost certainly not
consider that but um
but wow what what could that do to
somebody
what might that do i mean the people
that experienced it
it was transformative for them i think
that
as a sort of symbolic confrontation with
your own mortality
that could be amazing because i think
that's one of the best things that
can happen to a person is to remember
the the preciousness of life to remem
remember that one day they will die and
everyone they love will die
and so to integrate that into your daily
life so that you're not
spending your time stupidly or hatefully
or purposelessly or whatever
um so yes that that is a part of the
ceremony and then on top of that they're
you know undergoing a pretty
intense psychedelic experience as they
stare into the stars
in a grave um and
uh yeah so i think and they still do
this
and does everybody do it uh no
the there are different different
sort of it's almost like a play the the
ritual where you have different
characters people have different roles
in the church
so there there's like a military there's
like an army
and a boga army and they carry
fake weapons and they dress in military
clothing and they are like the spiritual
warriors who guard the ceremony
with these like wooden guns and uh
and then you have um all these different
characters that come out
um where people are you know being
there's like a there was sort of like
almost a native american type character
which was interesting to see in central
west africa
with like a feather kind of headdress
and you have um
all different there's a lot of costume
changing um
different dances different songs for
different moments
and so some of those people that are
performing and dancing will take a small
amount
then you have uh people that need the
specific intervention of being
buried alive and those people will take
whatever amount is appropriate for their
age and gender
and the purpose of this
uh very burying ceremony then you have
there's a sort of area
where people who were taking really high
doses
for medical purposes would just lay
um lay in a recessed
kind of i don't want to call it like a
dungeon but it had it had a
it had a uh slightly dungeon like
character you could say
um you know it was like a recessed pit
kind of zone that was uh behind the
central ceremonial space
and they lay in that area um
body to body against one another and
many of those people were
almost anesthetized by the ebola because
at high doses it will cause
unconsciousness it is
one of its primary pharmacological
mechanisms as a
nmda antagonist like xenon or ketamine
so yeah so that's but it's really
it's different things for different
people again this is not something that
we
uh do in our own culture we don't
we barely even think about it about like
what
like what these diseases are for
different people
for different purposes it's we have a
more kind of one-size-fits-all
uh attitude toward treatments um
but uh yeah so i can't even remember
wild yeah it's really amazing it's
really
really
um really really amazing
like i i definitely rank it
up there among just one of the most
amazing things i've ever seen period
not even in the realm of travel or
drugs or anything like that just in an
absolute sense
it felt like something that was so
such a beautiful hybridization
of medicine and religion
and entertainment and dance and
like you know all these things that are
totally separate in our culture like
a dance party and the treatment of
disease like those are would never be
mixed either
um but they should be mixed that would
be
that would make treating diseases way
better than this isolating experience
that we normally have
right i went to i was fortunate
like very fortunate um to be able to go
to a potlatch in canada
which is kind of um a native ceremony
in this big house and they've completely
filled
there's a fire in the middle there's a
hole at the top of this house so it's
filled with smoke
and it's this dance i'm gonna like
butcher my
representation of it but there's a dance
with masks and people kind of embody the
spirits that they're dancing
and it was the most wild i think it
well it was up there with one of the
most wild experiences i've ever had
because it
it felt like being it was so removed
from what i'm used to
in um in this like you know living in a
condo in the city it was
it was wild so
yeah so bad that those are so few and
far between and that didn't have there
there were no drugs in that one there
was smoke
um that was that was it but it was still
like
it was crazy yeah yeah i mean it's it's
uh
there's a lot of really powerful things
in those rituals a lot of people
contacted me sort of enraged by the
animal sacrifice
i mean i am actually amazed by how
bothered by animal sacrifice most people
are it's one thing if you're a vegan
if you're a vegan and you hate animal
sacrifice fine then
fair enough okay then you you have
fought for that right but if you eat
meat
and you are also going to say that
animal sacrifice in a religious context
is bad it's like where do you think your
food comes from like what do you how do
you think we're like
you're you're angry at these wheatiests
in
central west africa for sacrificing like
three chickens
that they almost certainly ate the meat
of later like
i don't know but but again that's what
you got bugged about the chicken
sacrifice yeah well people are very some
people
it's hard it's like that is it's hard
it's hard it's hard to deal with that
kind of thing but
yeah but it really is but uh after
seeing that you're like you're
the thing that the thing that caught
your attention was the uh
the chicken sacrifice uh okay that that
and also the children
because in in you know the idea of
giving
a psychedelic to a child is is just like
unthinkable in our culture totally
unthinkable
and and i don't really
have a take on it other than to say that
i've
certainly met a lot of people that did
use psychedelics as young children
who are fine today i'm not going to
recommend
anyone do that it's within a specific
cultural context
but um but yeah there's there's just a
lot of things that they do differently
and i think that
um you know animal sacrifice is shocking
as it should be
like it should it should it it's
intended
to produce an effect and to you
shouldn't
live a life where you've never where you
eat meat and you've never seen an
animal killed like that's i think just
totally
a product of our times where people uh
want to be so
detached from the reality of what their
practices actually mean
where you know where their electronics
come from
where the resources that produce all the
things in their lives come from
where their meat comes from where their
food comes from no one is thinking about
that
and i think it's very telling how
horrified people are to even see
something like the death of a chicken
yeah that is telling yeah that's telling
so it's a bit entertaining it's
entertaining to me it's actually just
really
sad but yeah
i'm like drowning in lack of
entertainment
uh okay this was an interesting story
so again i was youtubing you
okay and i came across a video from
quite a while ago
about this guy louis who had a major
major
major brain injury and was comatose
and his mom gave him
i'm just too or ambient sorry just to
calm down muscle spasms and he woke up
do you have any idea how that could work
not that ambien should be just the
overall treatment for brain injuries
but it worked for him right yeah and
there's a book that's impossible to get
unfortunately
um called i believe the title of the
book is hope and brain damage
and yeah it's just not available i
shouldn't even say it because it's just
going to cause people to
ask me where to get it i have no idea
it's just me afterwards on google being
like
damn it but it was written by
a physician who is kind of the leading
expert on this
paradoxical effect of ambien on some
people who have suffered
traumatic brain injuries or strokes or
various other types of brain injuries
and um and uh
and he has a hypothetical mechanism for
how this might work that i
don't believe has been experimentally
evaluated so if i were to even begin to
discuss that that would just be me
repeating what he told me he thinks is
happening
but they have done neuroimaging studies
and they have found
that in these regions that are damaged
by the traumatic brain injury or by a
stroke or by these various other causes
um that uh
that there is a actual like
restoration of metabolic activity in a
region
that is otherwise uh damaged and
non-active they have this is not so they
have actually
demonstrated that this is happening
under the influence of ambien that this
transient
metabolic alteration is taking place and
what's really
most paradoxical about it is you have
ambient which is uh it's not a
benzodiazepine
structurally chemically speaking but
pharmacologically
it's acting pretty much identically to a
benzodiazepine
it's a positive allosteric modulator
gaba a receptor
and uh and so there's nothing that you
can really point to with ambien
and say like why is ambien doing this
and
valium isn't doing it uh that's kind of
one of the first big
questions about why what it is that
gives ambien this
property his hypothesis was that
there's some kind of epigenetic
alteration that occurs with some of
these brain injuries
that causes a kind of reversal of the
functionality of the gaba a receptor
and that uh and that in those people
zolpidem is uh actually having like
the opposite effect that it does on a
normal person where instead of
uh preventing the
or rather instead of uh facilitating
the entry of negative ions into the
neurons so that it's less likely to fire
um
it is actually going to block that
and make it more likely to fire that's
his kind of ultra
reductionist explanation for how this
way and that might be the case i don't
know
um but uh yeah it's it's
really fascinating it's really it's
really amazing because
you don't encounter things like that
very often that you have a
you know someone who has
a brain injury of some kind and they can
take a small molecule
medication and have a transient
pharmacological
improvement in functionality that lasts
as long as the drug lasts and
i made that piece a long time ago i
haven't watched it since i made it it's
probably from 2000
i don't know really interesting from
2014
okay all right i'll link it below okay
it's a good it's a good clip
yeah i mean i do remember kind of
heartbreaking but it's a good one
yeah i do remember like some of the
tests
that i did on camera weren't as like
rigorous as i might have hoped
it's yeah it was a long time ago but
it's a very interesting subject and
i i do wonder if there have been um
new pieces of information about it that
have emerged in
recent years um yeah i would
yeah i would like to see what the
the current state of understanding of
that is and if someone has discovered
something new since i would report it on
it
yeah if it's moved at all okay switching
directions
yeah before i let you go um
why why are why is everything
not everything but why are all these
drugs illegal like
what happened to make do you know the
background and
if there was something in the
pharmaceutical industry or if it was
journalists or what happened
to start i guess the war on drugs
because i've been watching peaky
blinders
which is an excellent show if you need a
netflix show
i don't know what it is you don't know
peaky blinders oh my god
it's great it's great it's it's about um
i think it's about people in the 1910s
and 1920s these gangsters
um in birmingham and
as it's really good if you like kind of
like dark
thrilling fairly violent
sex-filled tv shows which is what i like
um
but but there's like there's opium
there's cocaine
there's there's alcohol although that
was made illegal back then i guess in
the states
but what happened and why are all these
drugs illegal now
oh it's such a complicated story and any
attempt to reduce it to a single factor
will not explain the entirety of it you
know there are
strong racial components racism is a big
one
attempts to control people there were
medical misunderstandings there was
well-intentioned attempts to
help people you know it's a combination
of every imaginable
social force one that i think is not
examined
as frequently as it should be is public
support
you know we see to this day how much
public support there is for prohibition
whenever we decide a drug is bad right
that's that's the crucial
evolution that we have not culturally
made that we need to make we need to
stop
saying okay prohibition of course it was
terrible made no sense with alcohol that
we know that was
made no sense with cannabis but now that
we've got opioids now that we now it's
different we've got to prohibit opioids
because those are bad
those are bad well we always thought it
was bad that's the whole point
so and then later we realized well we
thought it was bad but it turned out
that prohibition was worse
so i think that that's the kind of trick
is to not
not let your idea that something is bad
force you to believe that prohibition is
the solution which
like it continues you hear it all the
time like oh well fentanyl
fentanyl is bad though fentanyl is hoy
it kills people
we've got to prohibit it it's terrible
oh synthetic cannabinoids i mean those
are those are terrible we've got to
prohibit those come on
like we still do this all the time
and and then you know what happens so
everyone is up in arms about
the opioid epidemic so-called opioid
epidemic
okay um so what is the these these
nefarious
uh pharmaceutical companies they
conspired to trick
all these innocent physicians who had no
idea that opioids were addictive
and no one knew that opioids were
addictive and if it weren't for mortimer
sackler
then rubbing his hands and cackling at
purdue
then then you know no one would have
ever
uh ever prescribed opioids well of
course that's
as much as people want that to be the
case it's not how it happened and
really at every link of the chain
there was either someone who was
knowingly turning a blind eye or people
who didn't want to take responsibility
for their own actions and
and what happens when you don't take
responsibility for your own actions well
then you live in a society
where you have people who try to control
you
right you say oh it turned out that they
were too liberal and they're prescribing
of opioids and i couldn't control myself
so the government needs to come in and
prevent them from being prescribed
that's not the direction that things
should head instead
there should be an emphasis on education
personal responsibility
responsible prescribing practices by
physicians and
an understanding that opioids carry
a really high risk for dependence
problems
for for some people um because yeah i
mean i get emails all the time from
pain patients who talk about how tragic
it is that they
can't get opioids as a result of the
crackdown and you know
it's it's like that is that is tragic
that really is tragic i was um yeah i
agree with the
people need to be educated and people
need to be talking about it because i'm
i was i mean my audience knows i was on
oxycontin for a year
and i ended up physically dependent on
it because
that's kind of what happens when you
take high dose of oxygen for a year
right but i was it was
very very difficult for me to get and
that
drove me to enough pain that i was
suicidal right so there was
it took way too long to put me on
something given the fact i really needed
it
and then at least when i was on it i was
aware that
i knew that i didn't know what opiate
withdrawal was like but i knew that it
existed so when it happened i was like
okay this is because i was on a drug and
now i'm withdrawing from it and that
helped me understand but with some of
these other pharmaceuticals
we went into this a bit last time i
think um
because they're treated in a different
way then
these dangerous drugs are treated
because they're illegal
um there's no education around the
dangers
at least i wasn't aware of a lot of the
education around the dangers of
other pharmaceuticals that actually have
dangers and
have um withdrawal and because they're
legalized
and in this different categories of safe
drugs people don't understand the
dangers there
it's a tricky situation yeah it's very
yeah it's
it's hard because people actually
separate
illegal and legal drugs as if there's a
pharmacological distinction where legal
drugs are safe
pharmaceutical drugs are safe illegal
drugs are dangerous and uh
and so you think okay this was
prescribed by a physician it was
dispensed by a pharmacist
it's in a pill bottle i as long as i use
it
this way it's all going to be fine and
it's not that simple there needs to be
a sort of comprehensive understanding of
these substances
that we just don't get in our culture
in our culture which is saturated with
drugs that's the
like it almost like some people would
almost say like oh that's ridiculous you
couldn't
spend how much time could you possibly
spend on drug education in school
but it's like well there's a lot of
drugs
isn't it isn't one in five i'm pretty
sure one in five and it could be worse
given kovid because everybody is on some
sort of antidepressant like the
the uh rates of prescription for
benzodiazepines and antidepressants has
skyrocketed with covid
but i thought what i last read was one
in five people in the states are on some
sort of psych med
oh yeah which is a huge percentage of
the population so there could easily be
a few courses in school
that taught you how to deal with these
things when they're inevitably
introduced to you sometime in your life
it's
really ridiculous that we're not there
yet it's dangerous given the fact that
everyone's on medication yeah and it can
i think it could all be integrated into
you know teaching neuroscience and
pharmacology it's all kind of
they're all interconnected in such a way
that it doesn't need to be
like an extra drug course it could be in
chemistry even
learning about areas maybe of the brain
and what they work on
i mean no that's chemistry it's usually
more of a like uh you know neuroscience
thing but like
yeah it's it's cartoon versions for
younger kids
i'm only half joking i wish i'd known
better when i was younger
yeah no i think it i think it's all
really interesting and useful it
certainly wouldn't be bad to teach
children about
pharmacology i think would be really i
was obsessed with poisons
you know from the very beginning um so i
think that people would actually be
kind of receptive to it but yeah
it's it's very tricky um
it's it's very hard with the personal
responsibility aspect as well because i
i know that uh it's a lot to ask
like a normal person especially you know
older people
you know you can't expect them to
like learn pharmacology from scratch in
order to take a medication like i get
that it's
it's very complicated um but
i think the ideal situation is one where
the substances that people want are
available should they want them
and they are assumed to
take responsibility for their own
actions so if they get into trouble with
it
then that is something that they don't
have to blame
a pharmaceutical company or an alcohol
distillery or a
tobacco company but they recognized it
was a choice that they made
and that medical resources are available
to help them
either discontinue use or
[Music]
modify their use pattern in a more
constructive way that would be the ideal
situation
yeah i think that would be the ideal
situation at least you could be told hey
you know what this drug
when used improperly or perhaps used is
can be very dangerous but the research
is out there read it
and if you need it because sometimes
being in pain
in fact a lot of times being in chronic
pain is actually more dangerous than
being on opiates
right like you're supposed to be
weighing these things so it's not good
to
force people to like to make a decision
for these people
um without understanding why they're
after a certain drug
but then those people should be well
aware of the dangers of the drug
right yeah yeah it's it's
yeah okay
wow thank you very much for coming on
again that was fun
yeah i know it's always fun brightened
up my
cove a day oh good um and where can
where can people find you online um
yeah you can i have a like a sort of
chemistry oriented
podcast on patreon patreon.com hamilton
morris i have
a tv show which you can most easily
watch on
amazon and i recently
republished a small book that i've got a
copy of it right here it's
that is a like an old guide to
uh milking bufo alvarius that is now
revised
that has a uh description of how to
sustainably
produce five miodmt in countries like
canada where it's legal
um and uh what yes
this is a book that i should have yeah
you should yeah yeah it's you can get it
it's uh
www psychedelic toad of the sonoran
desert dot com
and uh and and 100 of the
profit goes to charity so it's a it's a
nice hand printed
uh toad information source
that also has this nice
environmentally oriented chemistry and
uh and it goes to charity so it's a nice
little thing
that's amazing well thank you very much
for coming on it's always fun talking to
you so you kind of remind me of somebody
who should be in like
like a character in sherlock holmes or
something
like it's fun anyway that's a compliment
okay the compliment
okay okay thank you hamilton okay have a
good day talk to you later
[Music]
you